jetzt steckt die da schon wieder hallo
mein name ist luca und erst mal ein ganz
ganz großes sorry dass ich hier so
komplett fertig aussehen ist aber
eigentlich eh nichts neues allerdings
lag ich die letzten zwei tage nur in
meinem bett flach mit magen-darm-grippe
und habe quasi den ganzen tag des
weltserie klappt wenn ich das sagen
würde auf jeden fall ging es mir echt
scheiße scheiße ist das passende wort
hörte das allerdings soll es heute um
etwas ganz anderes geht uns warum das so
leander ward keine ahnung was das ist
allerdings ist dass der schauplatz der
heutigen doppelfolge namens dommes
steckt fest krieg endlich dein leben in
den griff und natürlich habe ich mir für
diese heutige reaction auch wieder
einige bingo sätze von euch rausgesucht
aus den kommentaren marianne sagt
englische wörter falsch stimme nimmt
sich heimlich oder nimmt sich einfach
snacks das ist nicht dein ernst oder
mensch du spinnst du messages größer wie
der von einem nashorn ja ich würde sagen
wir starten einfach mal mit dem video
[Musik]
das
28 sekunden und viel zu viel nackte haut
die marianne für eine gleichmäßige
bräune hier wirklich hat auch die dame
sucht immer noch für ihre tochter
kindergartenplätze
daher hatte doch einen clown für ihre
tochter organisiert der letztendlich ein
stripper war
[Musik]
doch auch dieses nach vorn und jetzt
habe ich den beweis dass arsch ist
größer wie der von einem nashorn
oh mein gott wusste die person er sich
auf diese folge reagieren werde gomez
ist größer wie der von einem nashorn
[Applaus]
herzlichen glückwunsch du bist unser
heutiger erster bingo gewinner als
sieger die platte wie es regelt sich die
dame hier wieder auf so einer
wasserrutsche rum
[Musik]
sorry schaut euch das
da ist einfach dass jan es ist wie wenn
so ein wal strandet
a
sorry aber dass das muss doch nicht sein
solche aufnahmen der stille und oder
winters musst du wirklich für dich und
deine tochter gab sich noch mal kurz das
fenster auf sorry karneval dann saßen
wir da so in entspannter atmosphäre und
habe ich hier noch mal so lage licht ist
ganz wichtig ist dass den erklärungen
ausflüge gemacht und vor allem dass sie
sie auch in den kindergarten an
das muss man wirklich sagen die tante
marianne die kümmert sich richtig um die
bäume das finde ich echt schön zu sehen
meine ganze ton sport so eine konstante
höhe weil diese vollidioten der trommel
und trompete spielen muss das sein muss
dass sein rtl2 muss leute schaut euch
das schaut euch einfach an
ja kein kommentar die mama steckt fest
nach jeder ecke
denke ich
kann ich noch
und dann kommt sowas wahnsinn weil ich
ja jetzt ist keine kleine noch kleiner
stelle vor dies ein bisschen größer ab
einig dass dann ist vor ihren
spielkameraden oder fünf um mein gott
leonie die arme alters hört euch mal vor
die ist mit ihren freundinnen im
schwimmbad und dann sagen die freude
denn von irgendwie so hey wir essen das
da hinten er feststellen wie peinlich
ist das denn und das ist denn die dame
das wäre echt fremdscham sport gesunde
ernährung dass ich glaube ich glaube das
allein hilft nicht bei der dom
ich glaube da man bräuchte eine
fettabsaugung
sondern vier tonnen fettabsaugung
[Musik]
also diese teile hier sehen so ein
bisschen aus wie blau penisse mit einer
gelben und im gesicht drauf
coole kinder schwimmbad deko ich kann
mir das nicht vorstellen wie träume drei
minuten bei der wassergymnastik war und
sich danach wie schwimmmeister raum so
zehn stücken ein
doch jetzt schlägt die da schon wieder
alter
richtig da nicht raus damit
[Musik]
von meinem geistigen auge schon gesehen
die flexen das hallendach und holen die
mit kran mitsamt der rutsche daraus vor
diesem video ging es mir schon schlecht
der wegen magen darm und so und jetzt
will sich auch noch mein gehirn
übergeben
du hast keine gelenke also überhaupt
nichts gegen doppel persönlich ich bin
dumm ist einer der witzigsten menschen
auf ganz youtube oder allgemeinen
schauspiel technisch aber gelenke mich
kommt zu falls werder nur fett überall
es ist ein job doch mal bestellt sich
ein salat sich das noch erleben darf
alter okay das ist ein spannendes
experiment gerade das aus
nein
leute wir haben erst mal das experiment
war ja dass ich tante marianne und
leonie was richtig geil fettiges unseres
zu essen holen und donner holt sich
einen salat und wenn du es geschafft
hätte nur bei ihrem salat zu bleiben
hätte sie definitiv den respekt von
tante marianne und
ihre tochter kam wahrscheinlich noch
nichts dabei denken allerdings hatte
dann das hier abgezogen leute dadurch
haben wir nämlich auch einen neuen bingo
gewinner und zwar louis soll domingo
dominiert sich heimlich oder nimmt sich
einfach snacks also louis herzlichen
glückwunsch den zweiten platz gemacht
heute bekommt man auch einmal von
anlagen dann saß ich da mit meinem sohn
noah und leon hätte ihre pommes nicht
ganz aufgeregt film hat mich da
zwischendurch mal ein bisschen bedient
heißt kein anderer fühlen haben und was
to me oder an sondern auch wird es doch
lässig ein joghurt dressing über könnte
es sein dass du hier verarscht und der
uniform ist klaus ja alleine zweimal das
mit umdrehen hat wegen der auch so ein
park missgeschicke im schönberg passiert
sind ich glaube im großen und ganzen hat
dumme gesehen das ist wahnsinnig spaß
mal was zu unternehmen und nach raus zu
kommen
die spatzen will also da wo du mir jetzt
ihre tochter anmelden will vielleicht
kein direkter zu sagen wir sind nicht so
richtig weiß ich sehe das so zu hause
reden ist ihr von süßigkeiten dass wir
dann gesagt haben okay jetzt komplett
zuckerfrei damit kommen die kinder super
klar die kriegen dann jetzt anstatt
lucia oder ein joghurt kriegen sie dann
eben auch zuckerfrei zuckerfrei alter
das wissen ja die hölle für dumme ist
denn hier passiert endlich ja aber super
orden lehmanns gekocht habe ich auch
kriegt die kurve oder oder was also mir
kommt es mittlerweile so vor als wenn
die dame wirklich gerade so ein
veränderungsprozess durchläuft die leoni
will angemeldeten zuckerfreien
kindergarten jetzt war sie hier gerade
einkaufen hat es anscheinend auch noch
richtig gut gekocht für die marianne war
das sieht gesund noch alles gibt gemüse
dort bist du krank
lass dich warum abendkleid nein ich
hoffe doch toll das war ja nur zu mir
gesagt hat sich stolz auf mich ist
und dann hat sie mich auch noch einen
arm genommen da wusste ich jetzt bin ich
auf dem richtigen weg okay leute ich
glaube da ist dem leaf ein anderer
mensch an erzählte durch das heutige
video ist allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt es tut
mir leid das diese aktion vielleicht ein
bisschen beschissener war als die
anderen reactions immer weil ich bin
echt total krank schlapp und musste mich
auch während dieses videos dreimal dort
aufs bett setzen dass sich hier nicht um
falle von daher werde ich dennoch
gefallen hat darf gerne einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video ihr da schreibt
mir gerne für die nächste folge dumme
einerseits eine folge in die kommentare
wie beispielsweise tom im knast oder so
und halten bingo satz wo ich denke dass
dieser satz dran kommen wird in der
nächsten folge wenn ihr mich zu dem noch
kostenlos unterstützen wollen würde ich
mich sehr freuen wenn ihr bei fortnight
diesen code eingibt luca als support
creator co2 gerade diese nacht
rausgekommen die tage kommt auch ein
neues video dazu und ja das video jetzt
auch vorbei
[Musik]